Before you try riding your bike, walk next to it and practice pressing on the brakes...
...until you get a feel for how they work.
Then, sit on your bike.
Place one foot on one of the pedals, and place your other foot on the ground.
When you're ready, push off with your foot that's on the ground....
...and see how long you can glide on your bike without pedaling.
Keep your eyes forward and look toward where you want to go,...
...which will help you balance.
If you feel yourself starting to tip,...
...place your foot back on the ground to catch yourself.
Keep doing this until you're comfortable balancing on your bike.
Then, do the same thing again. But this time, start pedaling with your feet.
Continue pedaling and steering in the direction you want to go.
The faster you pedal, the easier it will be to balance.
If you need to come to a stop, stop pedaling and press down on the brakes.